- It's the story of a real mummy
the real world thought was
fake until a 1970s
TV show inadvertently
exposed the gruesome truth.
This is "Dark History."
[somber music playing]
October 4, 1911--
a gang of bandits
stop a train carrying
$400,000 in cash.
They board the train, ignoring
the screams of passengers
as they frantically
search for their bounty.
But it's nowhere to be found.
They stopped the wrong train.
A posse forms to track down
the gang of thieves who
have managed to only
steal $46, a watch,
and two jugs of whiskey.
The gang splits up.
One member, Elmer McCurdy,
starts a gunfight.
He hits none of the
lawmen, but one hits
him, directly in the chest.
Elmer McCurdy dies instantly.
His body is taken to
the Johnson Funeral Home
in Pawhuska, Oklahoma.
There is no immediate
kin to contact,
so it is embalmed,
remaining preserved for when
someone comes to claim it.
Surely someone will
come to claim it.
But no one does.
So the funeral
director improvises.
He dresses Elmer's body,
puts it in street clothes,
props him up like
a taxidermy trophy,
and leans a rifle by his side.
He then charges people
$0.5 to look at it.
For five long
years, Elmer's body
remains in the corner of
this Oklahoma funeral home,
until one day, he's claimed.
Two men requesting the
body present themselves
as Elmer's long lost brothers.
The funeral director
is suspicious.
But the attraction
has grown old,
and he feels the body
deserves a decent burial.
It doesn't get one.
The two men, James
and Charles Patterson,
bore no relation
to Elmer McCurdy.
But as carnival proprietors,
they knew a good attraction
when they saw one.
In the ensuing
years, Elmer's body
is featured in carnivals,
haunted houses,
and wax museums.
Elmer's corpse is even
used to promote films,
like the 1933 movie, "Narcotic."
The body's gruesome tour
goes on for 60 years,
during which the real
story of Elmer McCurdy
fades into obscurity.
His very real corpse comes
to be seen as nothing more
than a scary prop until 1976.
By then, Elmer's body is
featured at the Pike Amusement
Zone in Long Beach, California
as part of the Laugh
in the Dark haunted attraction.
His corpse now hangs by
a noose in a dark corner
of a second rate haunted
house, a bad prop
provoking a fleeting scare.
That year, Pike
Amusement Zone is serving
as a shooting location for
the television program,
The Six Million Dollar Man."
As the show's art director
makes small adjustments
to the scene's background, he
tries to move what he thinks
is merely a hanged man prop.
But in doing so, he accidentally
tears Elmer's arm off.
He tries to glue the arm back
on until he notices the bone.
On April 22, 1977, Elmer is
buried in Guthrie, Oklahoma.
In order to make sure his
body is never again disturbed,
two feet of concrete is
poured over his coffin.
Elmer McCurdy, a failed
bandit in life who saw much
more of the world in death.
And for you, a cautionary tale--
the next time you find yourself
looking for some cheap thrills,
you might want to
look a little closer,
because sometimes, the imaginary
can be very, very real.